Wissenschaftler haben eine künstliche Sonne
geschaffen.
100.000 Grad ist sie heiß und steht in den
USA.
Was haben sie damit herausgefunden?
Und können sie uns damit vielleicht vor gefährlichen
Sonnenstürmen schützen?
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler haben
auf unserer Erde eine künstliche Sonne geschaffen.
100.000 Grad ist sie heiß und steht in den
USA.
Was haben sie damit herausgefunden?
Und können sie uns damit vielleicht vor gefährlichen
Sonnenstürmen schützen?
Clixoom Science & Fiction heute mit Jacob
von Breaking Lab, abonniert Breaking Lab,
nur dann verpasst ihr auch dort keines der
coolen Videos;) Herzlich willkommen.
Heute mit also mit Jacob von Breaking Lab
Dort gibt es übrigens aktuell ein Hammer
Video zum Thema So sieht ein Schwarzes Loch
von innen aus.
Das sind noch spannendere Objekte im Weltraum
Der Link ist in der Videobeschreibung und
kommt nochmal am Ende des Videos.
Los geht’s!
Biie Jacob!
Ausblick
Ohne die Sonne, kein Leben.
Kein Wunder also, dass die Wissenschaft dem
Zwergstern auf den Grund geht.
Die Sonne ist etwa 100x größer als die Erde,
rund 150 Millionen Kilometer von uns entfernt
und an der Oberfläche circa 5500 Grad heiß.
Also nicht die einfachsten Bedingungen, um
die Sonne zu erforschen.
Aber genau das wollen Wissenschaftler der
University of Wisconsin-Madison jetzt machen.
Dafür haben sie ein unglaublich komplexes
Konstrukt entwickelt, um Vorgänge rund um
die Sonne besser nachzuvollziehen.
Konkret geht es darum, wie das magnetische
Feld der Sonne unser gesamtes Sonnensystem
beeinflusst.
Die Sonne ist bereits seit etwa 4,5 Milliarden
Jahren das Zentrum unseres Sonnensystems und
hat uns so das Leben ermöglicht.
Dabei setzt sie unglaublich viel Energie frei.
Hier ein Beispiel, das auch ziemlich gut erklärt,
warum wir die Sonne sogar auf der Erde so
gut als Energiequelle nutzen können, obwohl
sie fast 150 Mio.
Kilometer von uns entfernt ist: In einer (!) Sekunde
setzt die Sonne mehr Energie frei, als ALLE
Kernkraftwerke der Erde in 750.000 Jahren!
“A closer look”
Bei dem wissenschaftlichen Projekt der Uni
Wisconsin-Madison geht es ja um das magnetische
Feld der Sonne und wie dieses das Sonnensystem
beeinflusst.
Wie die Erde, besitzt nämlich auch die Sonne
ein Magnetfeld, das bis zu fünfmal stärker
als das irdische sein kann.
Die magnetischen Prozesse verursachen unter
anderem die sogenannten Sonnenflecken und
viele weitere Phänomene.
Für eine komplette Rotation benötigt die
Sonne rund einen Monat.
Diese Rotation lässt das Magnetfeld in Form
einer rotierenden Spirale entstehen, rund
um den Bereich des Sonnenäquators.
Dieses entstandene Magnetfeld polt sich alle
11 Jahre um, das wird “Sonnenfleckenzyklus”
genannt.
Bei der Arbeit mit dem “big red ball”
pumpen die Wissenschaftler Heliumgas hinein
und wandeln es in Plasma um.
Da die Sonne ein riesiger Stern aus Plasma
ist, ist das ein elementarer Schritt, um die
echte Sonne möglichst originalgetreu zu imitieren.
Natürlich gibt es auch das Magnetfeld.
Das wird überraschenderweise einfach durch
einen Magnet im Zentrum der Installation simuliert.
Zu guter Letzt lassen die Wissenschaftler
Strom durch die Mini-Sonne laufen und können
dann beobachten, wie Plasma und Magnetfeld
sich gegenseitig beeinflussen.
Ethan Peterson, der verantwortliche Wissenschaftler,
setzt der Installation aber auch klare Grenzen,
in dem er folgendes sagt: “Wir können die
Sonne nicht komplett nachbauen, das ist unmöglich.”
Aber, und das ist der wesentliche Vorteil
des Balles, mit dem Gerät könne man wesentliche
physikalische Vorgänge besser verstehen,
die rund um die Sonne geschehen.
Insbesondere ginge es darum, wie der Solarwind
entsteht.
Denn darüber herrscht totale Uneinigkeit.
Der Solarwind besteht aus geladenen Teilchen,
die so unglaublich heiß sind, dass sie sich
von der Gravitation der Sonne lösen und wegfliegen...mit
einer Geschwindigkeit von 400-800 km/h fliegt
das dann ins All...und ja, man kann sich vorstellen,
dass das für die Erde ziemlich gefährlich
werden kann.
Die Sonne verliert dadurch pro Sekunde etwa
eine Millionen (!) Tonnen an Material, was
aber im Vergleich zur Gesamtmasse wenig ist.
Und in unserem Sonnensystem gibt es Planeten,
die davon direkt getroffen werden.
Der Merkur ist ein Beispiel.
Er besitzt nur ein schwaches Magnetfeld und
keine Atmosphäre, deshalb ist der Merkur
ziemlich ungeschützt, wird getroffen und
ist allein aus diesem Grund extrem lebensfeindlich.
Deshalb ist das Magnetfeld der Erde für uns
ne ziemlich coole Sache, weil es fliegende
Teile aus dem All zusammen mit der Atmosphäre
abwehren kann.
Der Weg dieser heißen fliegenden Teilchen
Richtung Erde soll auch am “big red ball”
untersucht werden.
Die Forscher konnten sogar die sogenannte
Parkerspirale nachahmen, die nach dem berühmten
Solarastrophysiker Eugene Parker benannt ist.
Die Parker-Spirale ist die natürlich vorkommende
Spirale, die das Magnetfeld der Sonne formt.
Und die Sonne ist so stark, dass die Parker-Spirale
das gesamte Sonnensystem berührt.
Peterson sagt dazu: "Satellitenmessungen stimmen
ziemlich genau mit dem Parker-Spiral-Modell
überein, jedoch nur zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt,
sodass wir niemals in der Lage sein werden,
eine simultane, großformatige Karte davon
zu erstellen, wie wir es im Labor können".
Die experimentellen Messungen konnten nun
die Theorie bestätigen.
Aber es gibt noch eine Menge, was wir nicht
wissen, z.B. wie Sonnenwinde der Schwerkraft
der Sonne entkommen oder wie wir sie genauer
vorhersagen können.
Wie gefährlich können solche Sonnenwinde
oder im Extremfall Sonnenstürme denn für
uns werden, wenn sie auf die Erde zurasen?
Der größte Teil der Wolke wird im Abstand
von etwa zehn Erdradien durch das Magnetfeld
der Erde abgelenkt und um das von diesem Feld
beherrschte Gebiet, der Magnetosphäre, herumgeführt.
Jedoch kann die Magnetosphäre unter dem Druck
eines besonders starken Sonnensturms verformt
werden.
Die Folge sind elektrische Ströme, die bis
in die Ionosphäre etwa 100 Kilometer über
der Erdoberfläche eindringen.
Sie werden begleitet von Polarlichtern, die
aufgrund der Deformation der Magnetosphäre
bis in unsere Breiten sichtbar sind.
Die Schwankungen dieser Ströme induzieren
aber auch Überspannungen in großflächigen
elektrischen Leitungsnetzen, die dann auch
zum Ausfall des Netzes führen können, wie
z.B.
Am 30. im Oktober 2003.
Damals fiel aufgrund der hohen magnetischen
Aktivität im schwedischen Malmö für 20
bis 50 Minuten das Stromnetz aus.
Netzausfälle sind aber nicht alles, was dann
droht:
Zusammen mit den Gaswolken werden bei den
stärksten Sonnenstürmen auch sehr energiereiche
Teilchen von der Sonne ausgestoßen.
Sie können Erdsatelliten durchschlagen und
durch ihre ionisierende Wirkung die Elektronik
des Satelliten lahmlegen.
In der Ionosphäre erhöhen sie die elektrische
Ladungsdichte, die dann die Funkwellenausbreitung
beeinträchtigt.
So können GPS-Geräte während eines Sonnensturmes
durch die Laufzeitverzögerung der GPS-Signale
fehlerhafte Positionen anzeigen.
Vor allem aber gefährden die energiereichen
Teilchen die Besatzung der ISS, die dann kurzzeitig
einer sehr hohen Strahlendosis ausgesetzt
sind.
Die Belastung an der Erdoberfläche ist gering,
da die meisten Teilchen in der Erdatmosphäre
stecken bleiben.
Doch Menschen, die fliegen, können betroffen
sein.
Passagiere in Flugzeugen haben in 10.000 Metern
Flughöhe etwa 80 Prozent der Atmosphäre
unter sich gelassen und sind während solcher
Ereignisse schon deutlich stärker gefährdet.
Es ist also von großem gesellschaftlichen
Interesse, mit dem “big red ball” mehr
über solche Sonnenstürme zu erfahren.
Das UW-Madison-Team untersuchte auch die sogenannten
“Burps”, also das "Rülpsen" des Sonnenplasmas,
das die NASA-Wissenschaftler mit "Blobs in
einer Lavalampe" verglichen haben, nur halt
auf einer kosmischen Skala.
Diese Rülpse der Sonne sind mehrere hunderte
Male so groß wie die Erde!
Diese Rülpser werden zwar von Satelliten
beobachtet, aber niemand weiß, wieso es sie
gibt und was sie wiederum bewirken.
Mit der Minisonne konnten die Forscher sehr
ähnliche Rülpser sehen und nun verfolgen,
wie sie sich entwickeln.
Ich finde das jedenfalls extrem spannend und
glaube, die Forschung an der Sonne hat gerade
erst so richtig begonnen.
Und auch über Schwarze Löcher gibt es immer
wieder neue Ereknntnisse: So sieht ein Schwarzes
Loch von innen aus Das ist das aktuelle Video
von Breaking Lab.
Anklicken, anschauen und und auf jeden Fall
Breaking Lab abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!